hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen wir heute mal wieder zu einem
video auf das ich mich sehr freue
nicht denn wir reagieren mal wieder auf
to hot to handle in der letzten finger
weg reaction sind wir an der stelle hier
stehen geblieben und zwar hat sie gesagt
dass harry fake ist
es ist passiert aber du bist schuld ist
ich glaube erlebt warum sprichst du für
sie also harry hatte was mit francesca
und jetzt müssen die geld abgeben von
100.000 euro und jetzt streiten sich die
gruppen ich ganz ganz meine absolute
lieblingsstadt francesca hat eine
marionette gesucht und gefunden
jesus das machen marionetten also der
himmel ist blau und darum glaube ich
dass du es warst
jesus halt ist unhöflich
ich bin nur ehrlich es für dich ich bin
als einzige ehrliche und ich bin die
dumme klasse blick erstmal kurz
wie auch immer die heißt
dass die sich jetzt alle streiten aber
nicht aufgrund der tatsache dass es
passiert ist dass francesco herrig sich
geküsst haben sondern auch von der
tatsache dass
ja warum eigentlich fertig mit dir ja
[Musik]
rugby ach guck mal unsere hälfte lampen
buch ich hatte die heißeste senioren und
ich habe sie wie zur hölle konnte das
passieren
ist nicht schlimm francesca wenn nur
neun brauchst also ich bin auf jeden
fall hier wohl kostet sondern und
nichtwissen mindestens 20.000 hey das
ist halt das ding wir wissen bisher nur
was der bisherige regel verstossen
gekostet hat also einen kurs 3000 dollar
und die alle zusammen bekommen
hunderttausend dollar wenn sie einen
monat lang so etwas nicht machen
das preisgeld beträgt nun 97.000 dollar
der anblick sagt alles und der blick
sagt auch alles danke weiß ich nicht
buchhalter ist bald nichts übrig leute
küssen verboten
ja kürzen war eigentlich schon die ganze
zeit
aber unser rugby harry hat sich das
irgendwie nicht so ganz zu herzen
genommen
ich mag sie sie ist viel besser als er
braucht ihn nicht hat verein gelungen
ich bin nicht sicher aber es ist
grüppchen hat was gegen uns und ist
schon deshalb auf seiner seite
ja ich glaube ich dass die was gegen
euch haben aber du hast dich halte diese
ganze sache eingemischt meine liebe froh
dass ich wenn ich noch warum stolzieren
kann und jeder ihn glaubt francesca
harry ist es nicht wert hier in köln
wartet
ich will für francesca da sie ist
wunderschön
ok
das ist bei allen freunden so
man ist nur mit leuten befreunden weil
dann kann ich verdammt noch mal meine
muttersprache endlich mal da verknallt
sie sich die falsche person ja francesca
i'm here waiting for you liegt es an mir
oder habt ihr auch das gefühl dass haley
nichts dagegen hätte 3000 dollar mit
francesca zu verpassen
[Musik]
ok
ihr könnt doch beide nach köln kommen
ist es so schön und ich sitze in
quarantäne
guckt euch das erste tag in der neuen
losen welt neigt sich dem ende zu und
ein tisch für zwei verspricht ein
romantisches date
würde ich für diese erdbeeren schokosoße
grad geben wisst ihr was ich gerade
gegessen habe
im brot vorhin war kein licht
harry ist also ich bin eigentlich sind
beide die beiden bösen so wie ich meine
ich habe ja auf die folge auch er gibt
das war glaube ich vor 12 episoden hier
in denen harry und francesca sich kürzer
aber harry war schon so ausschlaggebend
aber franziska hat jetzt auch nicht
gesagt nein stopp stopp haben sie sich
in kürze waren beide ja in tools
schön auf seiner insel alter und ich
mache hier nach wie die sich geküsst
haben alter was ist ein falsch mit mir
klar mir ist aufgefallen dass du und
david geflirtet habt ja ja damit du
lernst bessere beziehungen aufzubauen
habe ich ein lied für dich und david
arrangiert das gibt euch die gelegenheit
herauszufinden ob es mehr als nur eine
körperliche anziehung gibt
o
[Musik]
danke allah ich heiße lava unsere lampe
aus dem buch haut wieder raus die ist da
dieser show und weil es in der zweiten
folge nicht mal wie das gerät heißt ach
jetzt bekommt allerdings die nachricht
haben wir darauf gefunden ist der hear
that the state hat durch der andere
das kann unangenehme situation war in
diesem lauf
was waren das dann bitte gerade für eine
kritische situation lana geht in diesem
raum an und sagt hey du hast ein date
aber nicht mit ihm wir mit einem andern
typ menschen nicht gesehen ziemlich
abstoßend den ehc bin gehe ich von halo
direkt ist
bei mir geht es eigentlich bei einem
date immer von halo dass die hände
voneinander und bauten eine emotionale
verbindung auf stadt eine körperliche
aber
dieses diese schale mit eingreifen
ich weiß nicht ob das so machen aber
bisher eine ganz verrückte peinlich los
gehts und die admira ganzen die kinder
selber hallo das ist doch links rechts
küsschen diese da ist es doch ist doch
geld vom konto auf meinen der kunde
konto ganz schön kameraleute betrage gut
sind dagegen ist passt
hat sie gerade gesagt ich trage roth
wir haben ja alle keine augen ich weiß
sieht man sich ja hast uns durchschaut
krass dass dieser kleine roboter an dem
das allerdings aufgebaut hat es hat auch
sehr fake die serie ließen sich christen
das wäre mein kuss mit den idioten nicht
mehr so schlimm mit dem ja wenn du wie
man anderen user kein idiot ist also
ganz es nicht
am liebsten würde ich euch das geld
geben und es ungeschehen machen aber sie
ehren wird die aussage von francesca
francesca vom ehre faktor würden wir
beiden echt ziemlich gut zusammen
ich werde dir ein bisschen freiraum
geben damit sie sich abwägen und den
rest vergessen kann
damals hatte sie eine höhere
[Musik]
harry du hast glaube ich nichts in der
birne aussagen rugby wir haben kein geld
verspielt uns besser kennen gelernt
ihr habt ihr euch besser kennengelernt
der blick sagt du bist sehr hübsch wird
sich aufgeschlossen eine lampe
gefährlich was will man mehr von dem
date aber das dürfte ja ich wusste dass
er mich gut findet
aber jetzt weiß ich dass er echt auf
mich stehen auch jetzt regt da dieser
auch noch weg
bei ihrer punzel schneewittchen kurs
yoga was ich habe das gefühl wenn ich an
jemanden interessiert film wird es
missbilligt und louis sind alle
begeistert was macht ihr dort ganz kurz
die leute waren so bei euch weil ihr
eine regel gebrochen habt aber in der
tiefe meines herzens mag ich erinnern
der sitzt tief jetzt der dolch in meiner
brust francesca aber nicht schlimm ich
kann ihn rausnehmen ich hab nämlich in
großen bizeps den kannst du dir mal
angucken wenn sie will dass man sie
bewundert sie wahrscheinlich auch noch
sagen
[Musik]
harry redet da gerade mit einem anderen
mädels und jetzt kommt's francesca rein
also es wird nochmals spannend zum ende
harry mit brandort liegt mir niemand
franchise wollte was nämlich kann das
jetzt verknüpfen das geld
rache ist nicht nur süß sondern auch
heiß
ja
es hat francesca mit herum gemacht
mit hayley heißt sie glaube ich und ich
sitze hier single wien in wien bringen
anders stelle sich das heutige video ist
allerdings auch beenden meine lieben
freunde wenn euch die heutige reaction
mal wieder auf theater hände gefallen
hat dallas kann einen daumen hoch unter
medien da schreibt immer unten in die
kommentare was ihr denkt wie viel die
jetzt verlieren werden an geld mit
dieser aktion von francesca und hayley
allerdings befinden wir uns jetzt auch
schon im auto meiner lieben freunden
findet die 12 die eingeweide würde noch
kein teil der luxus also noch nicht
meinen kanal abonniert hat dann klickt
dort gerne mal drauf ich weiß dass mehr
als die hälfte der leute die meine video
schon kein abonnent sind also liegt auf
den smiley und irischen video was auf
meinem 2 kanal online gegangen ist
klicken